the big movie for you was a time to kill
that was the one that broke the lead in
a large studio picture that opened big
and did well yeah and that's a game
changer once you're in a film like that
absolutely and they don't think of you
for the lead role right I mean you don't
have to go earn that
I go in
um to talk to the director about a a
another role very minor role had a
couple of scenes and I had this plan
going in
I need to be playing this league guys
got Jake Brigance so how am I going to
do this so I get in the meeting with Joe
Schumacher and I said hey who's playing
the lead role Jake Brigance he says I
don't know who do you think should
I remember I was smoking at the time and
I remember taking the cigarette at that
point and taking a nice hit and going
I think I should and he laughed that's a
great idea it's never happening well
because why because the studio isn't
going to bank on someone like you you're
not knowing at that point no way at that
time who were they thinking about Brad
Pitt I think so I think they were also
thinking about Woody and then um Woody
Harrelson and then
um Costner was it was also oh spoken
about it yeah what gives you the balls
to go in and say it should be me you
know when well one I believed it I
thought it should be me right
um two I knew I was taking a long shot
but I was gonna I knew I had a gap of a
window and if I don't throw it out now
well I'm not gonna know and I'm gonna
walk out here pissed off I didn't try
well Joe laughs his ass off and says
it's a great idea guess what it's never
happening
but a little thing happened around there
Sandra Bullock who was already in the
movie is row Ark has a movie open called
While You Were Sleeping it opens big all
of a sudden she can green light a movie
right that takes a little pressure off
well maybe we can look around for
somebody new for this role because
you're saying in other words in the
movies if you have a big star like
Sandra Bullock who's broken a movie that
maybe we don't need another guy we could
break somebody new there's leverage that
comes out there's box office leverage
when they're running their numbers and
what have you so we've got a lead role
and uh John Grisham gets approval of
that role right and they had somebody
else in mind he didn't approve them so
it's getting close to shooting the the
script's written the schedule set out
everyone else has cast all of a sudden
well let's try them out so they fly me
out and Jill Schumacher did a cool thing
he did it to it in a little dark Studio
on it was on um Mother's Day I think and
it was on a Sunday and he goes the
reason we're doing on Sunday and
Mother's Day is because even if you do
good you're not going to probably get
the role and I don't want it to go
against you that you tried it out for it
and didn't get it I mean maybe he was
trying to make you relax by just saying
you're not going to get this I think he
was just telling the truth he was like
look I'm I'm for it but I don't I don't
think this is going to work out I don't
think the student is ever going to
approve when you actually do the
audition are you a [ __ ] bundle of
nerves or are you able to dismiss all of
this like this is this could be a career
changer for me I mean man when I'm good
at an audition I'm I'm like [ __ ] it do
you have a [ __ ] up auditions absolutely
you're good at I'm better at it when I
[ __ ] it up and then come back you pop
the top on it when the ones when I'm not
good is when I've gone in and like uh
left a little bit in there were you
shocked when uh Schumacher gives you
this role because he's telling you the
whole time you're not going to get it
absolutely I got the call I think about
midnight in the middle of the desert I
got a call from Schumacher and John
Grisham he said you want to be Jake
Brigance hmm hell yeah I do